c'est
bonjour tout le monde bienvenue sur
l'émission minutes forme avec alison on
va voir les obliques donc le corps bien
droit bien alignés ok on va essayer de
tirer au maximum
donc là on rentre le ventre à chaque
mouvement voilà en dessous et donc on
rajoute un mouvement du bassin de haut
en bas
ok on renforcer la protection des
obliques donc là on contacte bien la
partie du bas du ventre
voilà et on souffre donc on peut
rajouter une variante on va tirer sur
les bras vers le haut
inspiré et si cette série vous pouvez la
faire en peu 10 et 20 répétitions et en
enchaînant gauche et droite on pouvait
faire trois fois quatre fois tous les
jours régulièrement quand justement
gardé une publicité au niveau du dos
avoir un corps équilibre
éloge dylan eut fait 10 à 20 répétitions
en alternant gauche et droite
quotidiennement pour ne pas déformer le
dos garder le dos et les épaules alignés
n'oubliez pas de rentrer votre ventre
afin d'optimiser cet exercice